c'est la question du jour faut-il
maintenir les élections départementales
et régionales les 13 et 20 juin
prochains
déjà reportée de trois mois elle devait
se dérouler en mars
l'exécutif a lancé un grand référendum
auprès des élus qui avaient jusqu'à midi
aujourd'hui pour se prononcer état des
lieux avec paul boyer et ilan chapelet
48% des maire d'indre et loire souhaite
le report des élections départementales
et régionales prévues les 13 et 20 juin
prochains
c'est le résultat d'une enquête de
l'association des maires
d'indre-et-loire 191 d'entre eux ont
répondu à cette consultation sur les 239
édiles que compte le département
un positionnement que comprend
l'association des maires ruraux d'indre
et loire
même si aujourd'hui sa vice présidente
estime que les mesures sanitaires prises
seront bien meilleures que lors des
municipales de mars 2020 à partir du
moment où les personnes pourront faire
leurs courses aller boire un café à une
terrasse de café et que nous espérons
d'ici là la majorité des personnes
auront pu être vaccinés tout du moins
les plus fragiles rien n'empêcherait
alors d'aller voter
l'intérêt du mois de juin c'est qu'on
peut effectivement énormément aéré et
puis on pourra éventuellement le faire
dehors
le conseil départemental a sondé les
principaux intéressés
sur les 38 élus 23 se sont prononcés
pour le maintien des élections
départementales en juin jean-gérard
paumier président du conseil
départemental d'indre et loire et
candidat à sa propre succession estime
quant à lui qu'il ne faut pas priver les
électeurs de ce moment de démocratie
bien sûr c'est compliqué organisées
notamment dans les mairies rural j'en ai
on en a tout à fait conscience mais
justement on a le temps nécessaire pour
y faire face c'est la sphère de l'état
de l'ensemble des élus et des des maires
je dirais et feront le maxi le maximum
mais il est dangereux de confiner la
démocratie d'ailleurs je crois savoir
que le prion du sénat en cas de report
ac a choisi de saisir le conseil
constitutionnel
un débat parlementaire doit avoir lieu
dès demain afin de déterminer si les
conditions sont réunies pour maintenir
les scrutins